et on va tout de suite prendre la
direction de barcelone on va retrouver
leslie singla elle couvre les événement
pour rt français de vue d'ailleurs
[Musique]
leslie bonjour alors vous êtes donc à
barcelone là où des incidents ont encore
éclaté hier soir en catalogne
particulièrement à barcelone la nuit a
été très mouvementée après une heure de
marche pacifique les manifestants se
sont dirigés vers le centre-ville et des
barricades ont été montées des
containers ont été brûlées des commerces
vandalisés et des pierres ont été jetés
sur les fourgons de police
alors les manifestants scander liberté
mort à l'espeme fasciste anti-fasciste
la plateforme liberté pour pablo à celle
avait convoqué des rassemblements dont
pas moins de trente villes du pays et
des incidents ont éclaté un peu partout
à madrid une centaine de policiers ont
chargé à plusieurs reprises contre des
centaines de manifestants alors au total
cette seconde nuit s'est soldé par 48
personnes arrêtées dont 29 en catalogne
et 10,9 à madrid
quelques heures avant la manifestation
le ministère de l'intérieur catalans
avaient demandé que les manifestations
soient sans violence et il avait prévenu
en cas de violences il devrait l'arrêter
alors ce n'est pas seul ce n'est plus un
seulement une colère contre la
condamnation de pablo à celle à mais il
semble que cela devienne un mouvement
aussi pour la liberté d'expression
oui exactement pour les espagnols c'est
maintenant devenu un symbole de la
liberté d'expression il ya d'ailleurs
quelques jours 200 personnalités du
monde de la culture ont signé un
manifeste comme le réalisateur pedro
pedro almodovar l'acteur javier bardem
alors plus que la libération de pablo à
sel il demande que les excès verbaux
commis lors de manifestations
artistiques culturelles ou intellectuel
soit exclu afin que les peines de prison
soient exclus du code pénal alors le
gouvernement a lui-même avoué il ya
quelques jours qu'il ne faudrait
réformer de la voie la plus rapide
possible les délits touchant à la
liberté d'expression car le rappeur
catalan a été condamné à neuf mois de
prison ferme pour 64 tweets publiés
entre 2014 et 2016 est une chanson
concernant le roi d'espagne
merci beaucoup leslie pour eux toutes
ces précisions leslie singles en direct
de barcelone